it's spreading chess table is bicoastal
the lark the live-action roleplay is
spreading we now have Chas and we have
has no Blas that's what it is Blas no
bats that's what it's very hard to keep
all because they keep changing their
name too but I think it currently is the
has the black house autonomous zone and
the black house autonomous zone is all
the way in Washington DC right across
the way from the White House they've now
taken over and vandalized that historic
church st. John's Church the President
Trump walked over to and held the Bible
up they vandalized it now they've
sprayed their name be haz on the church
and they are running roughshod over law
and order there with with total impunity
you now have examples in this area of
the the rioters I'm sorry I'm sorry the
peaceful protesters screaming at the
cops and this the screams have a racial
overtone to them so in one example you
have a black man yelling at a black
woman saying very insulting things the
black man is a rioter the black woman is
a police officer take a listen to this
disgusting diatribe
you know her excesses are upset with her
like a whole-step return over queen she
needs to work through that trauma the
hazard internalize
[Applause]
[Music]
so as this dirtbag is spewing this bile
at this woman you can see she's she's
just kind of taking it but she doesn't
seem happy doesn't seem like she's
having a nice time and this is a common
theme I see with all these leftist
protests is it's these dirt bag men
saying vile things to women because I
guess worries about sexism have gone
totally out the window row and they have
gone out the window they've gone out the
window in part actually because of
feminism because of this idea that men
and women are exactly the same and so
men shouldn't treat women in any sort of
special way well they don't they get
violent with them they say disgusting
things to them they've they follow them
to where they park their cars in their
driveway and film them disgusting
disgusting stuff but it takes out an
even weirder racial element when in the
knee they can't do two things at once it
can't fight sexism and racism they got a
I guess they have to pick it's a little
schizophrenic but then in the name of
fighting racism you now have white
leftists screaming at black cops in
defense of black people who they're
screaming at take a listen I have a
question for you you're white and you're
telling this to two black police
officers
you see the problem with that a little
bit oh no I don't because you know what
just because I'm white and I have an
experience racism myself doesn't mean I
can't fight for justice that part of the
system been a part of the problem
justice and black doesn't mean they're
not a part of the problem I know how to
save it to whoever because I'm white
racism is the white person's problem so
speaking of hysterical women obviously
her argument doesn't make a lot of sense
because they keep moving the goal posts
at one point we're told white people are
not allowed to say anything about this
then we're told that this woman says
basically only white people in this
situation should say anything about it
and we should listen to black people but
then she says we shouldn't listen to
those black people and the key here I
think is autonomous you here it's the
autonomous zone in Seattle it's the
autonomous zone in Washington this is
why I think it's got a it's has to do
with liberalism itself we all want to be
autonomous liberalism you're always
liberating yourself from the oppressive
past you're becoming more and more
autonomous and we are now we've become
so liberated so autonomous we've
liberated ourselves from ourselves so
this woman can say with a straight face
that she is speaking to the black
experience in America with greater
knowledge than the black people that
she's screaming it that we need an
autonomous zone within Washington DC
which is a federal zone within the
United States pretty soon we're gonna
have an autonomous zone within an
autonomous zone actually we already do
we have an autonomous zone within the
autonomous zones which are the
segregated zones which they're now doing
on the basis of race there is no limit
to that you will you will never there
will be no limit to the victim groups
this is why as intersectionalities has
progressed on the Left you've seen it's
gone from gay to gain lesbian to gay
lesbian and bisexual to gay lesbian
bisexual transgender to LGBTQ then
there's a queue for queer or questioning
LGBTQIA LMNOP it goes on there's no
limit this is why with gender it's gone
from men and women to men and
and intersects to men and women and
intersex and transgender to men and went
to 56 genders at least that was just at
last count probably there are more now
this will never end and the more we
become autonomous the more we liberate
ourselves it seems the less relation we
have to reality
we've now liberated ourselves into an
autonomous fantasy
[Music]
[Music]